bonjour tout le monde est bienvenu dans
la maison des maternelles je le disais
tout à l'heure à julie et thomas
aujourd'hui on va parler d'amour dans
cette émission alors évidemment qu'il
est amour 10
séparation
pourquoi en cette période pouvoir rester
que dans du positif dans paniquer
[Musique]
et on me dit que sheila a porté plainte
contre eux est ce qui vous choque le
plus dans la qui n'est pas de masque n'y
a pas de masse qui met pas de masque en
parler alors elle est la petite-fille
non plus et bien d'accord
[Musique]
il s'appelle kovi kovi de kapoor il est
indien âgé de 31 ans patron d'une petite
start up spécialisée dans les voyages et
il explique sur twitter que la semaine
dernière il a voyagé à l'étranger pour
la première fois depuis le début de la
pandémie l'occasion de réaliser que son
prénom ne laisse personne indifférent il
explique que quand il se présente et
qu'il dit bonjour je m'appelle coville
ça a le mérite de briser la glace dont
l'international comme vous l'avez tout
le monde à prendre le monde entier et on
a pas le vide par plaisir on a choisi
d'avoir co lead ont saisi par le préfet
rattraper le coc vide comme ça on n'est
naturellement immunisé et voyez moi je
suis naturellement immunisées vous ai
fait exprès de l'attraper au mont houy
ses commandes enfin simplement j'ai
jamais un ami qui avait co vide j'ai bu
dans son verre c'est tout c'est si
simple mais ça dépend de chacun ou en
revanche il raconte aussi que quand il
commande un café dans les chaînes vous
savez comme starbucks et bah il demande
au serveur de ne pas crier son prénom
à un café pour coville il faut éviter qu
vite kapoor qui ne manque pas d'humour
sur sa photo de profil il pose
évidemment avec une bière à la main une
bière de la marque
covin corona corona
au lendemain de l'agression à son
domicile du député lrm de saint pierre
et miquelon stéphane clé re toute la
classe politique a vivement condamné
cette attaque en déplacement à nice
emmanuel macron a dénoncé une agression
inacceptable et intolérable déplorant l'
intensification des violences contre les
élus
l'heure est grave mais omis suite à mon
post d'hier sur twitter montrant nos
chefs d'état en flagrant délit de
mensonge concernant l'anti mon compte a
été bloqué en effet quelques heures
avant booba avait publié une vidéo
dénonçant la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement quand vous êtes vacciné ne
risquez pas de contaminer les autres
alors simple coïncidence ou volonté de
boycotter les propos de l'artiste
quelles sont les vraies raisons la
gendarmerie a saisi des poissons de
haribo génial
c'est vrai
les dealers c'est haribo c'est beau la
vie y'a de la weed et du chief
depuis deux quinquennats en tant que
président de free j'ai maintenu le prix
des forfaits mobiles inchangé tout cela
je les fais pour vous alors c'est vrai
je suis sans doute pas un président
normal
j'ai plus de 50 ans et je ne porte pas
de rolex je ne vois pas de corona je
n'ai pas de fille cachée et je ne vous
trouverai pas un travail juste en
traversant la rue mon ambition est
d'être l'opérateur de tous les français
est de vous aider à communiquer sans
vous ruiner
[Rires]
la vidéo est devenue virale sur les
réseaux sociaux en inde plus d'une
centaine de personnes se sont rendus
vendredi soir à une fête d'anniversaire
donnée en l'honneur d'un chien son
maître a dépensé plus de 8000 euros pour
les deux ans dhabi son speech indien en
dépit des restrictions sanitaires du
couvre feu en vigueur et des
gestes-barrières les images diffusées en
ligne ont attiré l'attention de la
police trois hommes ont été arrêtés pour
avoir organisé cette soirée ils ont été
libérés sous caution un juge a ordonné
la libération immédiate de novak
djokovic qui est ensemble de rétention
depuis la semaine dernière l'annulation
de son visa finalement été annulée en
quelque sorte mais il pour il peut
encore être expulsé par les autorités du
pays c'est un peu compliqué marianne
murat vous êtes à melbourne en australie
il est non vaccinés on le rappelle le
tennisman serbe mais il a déjà eu le coc
vide et donc pour l'instant il n'est pas
sûr de participer au tournoi une info
qui a quelques minutes le juge en charge
de la sphère du visa australien de novak
djokovic
c'est marrant d'ailleurs qui s'appelle
novak novak durax c'est quand même non
mais c'est extraordinaire
je veux dire vous et c'est quand même
rigolo un cousin à maya c'est une amie
elle dit d'ailleurs un cousin bahia donc
c'est un cousin de madame est
un choix de vie de ma mère a eu une
troisième couilles 1 à cause du vaccin
et c'est pas une blague non est ce que
ça peut arriver ou bien il aurait comme
un eunuque sa troisième coupe c'est très
tôt dans le package
soir s'annonçait pas gérable je vous
jure que c'est vrai c'est moins
raisonnable c'est pas vrai bel et bien
possible non les gens qui diffusent des
fausses d'information depuis des mois et
des mois autour du vaccin qui laisse
apprécier aux gens que ce vaccin est
dangereux il faut qu'ils ne se vaccinent
pas qu'ils atterrissent à un réa ils
vont avoir des séquelles pour certaines
toute leur vie que d'autres vont en
mourir
effectivement il est temps molise l'erea
alors même qu'ils devraient ne devraient
pas y être s'ils étaient vaccinés les
désinformateurs il faut les courriers en
taule ça suffit maintenant
[Musique]
mes gars
la prod été
[Musique]
sur l'histoire de la personne qui a eu
un kyste c'est vrai elle a eu un kyste
donc au niveau des testicules et
sache-le les médecins ou mixtes à coup
que c'était les effets secondaires du
vaccin il faut arrêter de raconter
n'importe mais c'est ce qu'ont dit les
médecins arrêtent un peu alors qu'est ce
qu'ils disent est un témoignage de
première main oui aujourd'hui le médecin
je te dis que les médecins nous ont dit
on arrête arrête un peu
à fait valable jusque dans la mort les
obsèques des frères bogdanoff les
jumeaux les plus célèbres du paf âgé de
72 ans est décédé à six jours
d'intervalle de tous vides ont été
célébrées cet après midi en l'église de
la madeleine à paris ils seront inhumées
mercredi dans leurs villages dans france
à saint lary dans le gers et on
terminera pas je prends tout doucement
les hommes comme ils sont
jacou pu me mon âme à souffrir ce qu'ils
font
ça c'est le projet de ma vie j'y arrive
pas mais je voudrais à peindre je prends
tout doucement les hommes comme ils sont
accoutumés mon âme à souffrir ce qu'il
faut nommer tu te rends compte